today president trump's former attorney
michael cohen admitted to committing
tax fraud and bank fraud
yeah as a result cohen was immediately
rehired
by president trump he wants him back
he's like
that guy's very good uh it was just an
absolutely awful day for the president
yeah yeah bad news today president
trump's
as i say his former campaign manager was
convicted of eight counts of tax fraud
and his former personal attorney pled
guilty to bank fraud
yeah yeah when he heard president trump
said hey as long as my marriage is solid
in a good shape that's all i need i got
the marriage i'm in good shape
where is she anyway and what's her name
again yeah what's her name
malonia a uh
melanoma a well think of it
a nazi prison guard nazi prison guard
has been sent back to germany after
years of living
in the united states yeah after long
manhunt authorities found him
hiding in a trump rally and uh yeah he
was just
a new lawsuit claims that google tracks
users
wherever they are without their
permission yeah
yeah google ceo told the person filing
the suit we'll settle this
as soon as you get out of the shower
janice
it's like a house of parliament they're
like
[Applause]
we'll pass that one thank you very much
let's make that a law yes
the legendary 70s band the eagles have
overtaken michael jackson to have the
number one most popular album of
all time yeah
experts say it's due to a record number
of people going in for dental
it's
appointments
that's what they play when you're in the
chair they play peaceful easy feelings
that's right as they're ripping your
tooth out i feel bad for the people when
i mention the eagles that got really
excited
right yeah right and then i [ __ ] on them
yeah
but but if they're if they've seen the
show they should know they should know
they should know
yeah yeah we're more of an abba crowd a
uh
an initiative to allow recreational
marijuana in oklahoma
has failed in other words there's still
nothing fun to do
in oklahoma that's just
you